this pandemic of course it's not over  it's not over here at home  it's not over abroad and and that's why  we remain cautious yes  because of the vaccines we can start to  open up and we can  see normality in front of us and start  going on that road  back to normal and that's why we've been  able to move so many rules and  regulations domestically  but we still need people to get  vaccinated we still need our rules  around self-isolation  we'll be keeping border controls in  place you know wherever that makes sense  and it's important that we stay cautious  but at the same time i think we can be  optimistic as we look ahead what we are  planning to do on the 16th of august is  as you say first if you have been double  jab you won't need to self-isolate but  we will be certainly recommending  that they get tested and that will be  the advice it won't be compulsive